ce texte s'efforce de répondre à des
besoins urgents avec des mesures
d'application directe je pense notamment
à la valorisation du travail de nuit
tout en préparant et en consolidant
l'avenir du système de santé son cadrage
général répond à la double exigence
d'ambition et de soutenabilité qui doit
irriguer l'ensemble de notre action
publique il sera je le crois
profondément un socle solide sur lequel
nous pourrons continuer de construire
avec réalisme et
détermination bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans les grands débats nous
vous proposons de revivre la discussion
générale du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale c'est un texte
essentiel puisqu'il définit le budget de
la Sécurité sociale pour l'année 2024 le
gouvernement prévoit
254,7 milliards d'euros de dépenses de
santé mais aussi 3,5 milliards d'euros
d'économie ce projet de loi contient
plusieurs mesures phares comme une
grande campagne de vaccination contre
les infections au papilloma virus au
collège la gratuité des préservatifs
pour les moins de 26 ans ou la prise en
charge des protections menstruelles
réutilisables pour les femmes de moins
de 26 ans ou les plus
précaires ce projet doit les financement
de la sécurité sociale ne s'inscrit pas
dans une période normal si nous si ce
n'est plus le covid qui le soutend si
les perspectives d'inflation sont
meilleures pour l'an prochain ce PLFSS
doit répondre aux besoins d'un système
de santé qui reste à la fois formidable
et fragile les 19 milliards d'euros du
segéure investissement continue de se
déployer ce sont des murs des toits des
équipements ce sont des établissements
reconstruits ou rénové pour garantir les
de meilleures conditions d'exercice à
nos soignants une meilleure prise en
charge aux patients ce sont ces
engagements qui ont été au cœur de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2021 nous avons complété
les revalorisations du segégure à
hauteur de près d'un milliard et demi
pour accompagner les professionnels des
établissements de santé et
médicos-sociaux et leur garantir c'est
dans le dans le texte qui vous est
soumis à partir d'aujourd'hui et leur
garantir un socle de rémunération
reéhaussé en particulier pour celles et
ceux qui nous soignent la nuit le
weekend ou les jours
fériers ces moyens doivent accompagn
aussi la reprise de l'activité notamment
hospitalière avec les campagnes de
recrutement les plus satisfaisantes
depuis 10 ans qui permettent enfin de
rouvrir des lits d'ici la fin de l'année
nous devrions avoir rouvert 1000 à 1500
lits
d'hospitalisation tout cela vient
appuyer une action qui se déploie non
seulement à travers ce PLFSS mais aussi
dans son articulation avec un ensemble
d'autres vecteurs je pense tout
particulièrement à la reprise des
négociations conventionnelles avec les
médecins libéraux que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure et à la poursuite de la
proposition de loi Visante à de l'examen
de la proposition de loi Visante à
améliorer l'accès aux soins porté par
Frédéric Valtou dans chacune de ces
démarches nous sommes guidés par l'idée
de renforcer ce système afin qu'il
protège toujours mieux les Français et
qu'il puisse faire face aux difficultés
auxquelles il est confronté car oui ces
difficultés existent et je ne cèderai
jamais à la tentation de jeter dessus un
voile pudique ou de REP ou de peindre la
façade du haut de cette tribune la
transparence c'est aussi la marque de
cette confiance que je martè un mot
justement même si Thomas CASNAV y
reviendra évidemment sur le cadrage
budgétaire de ce texte il s'inscrit dans
un contexte d'ensemble contraint par
construction marqué par une inflation
qui a été forte cette année et qui
restera même plus faible l'an prochain
une dégradation des comptes de la
sécurité sociale notamment de la branche
maladie
certes nous étions à 21 milliards
d'euros de déficit en 22 et nous
finirons en dessous de 10 milliards en
2023 mais ce sont des chiffres mais ce
sont des chiffres importants et un fort
dynamisme des dépenses de santé je pense
notamment par exemple aux dépenses de
médicaments il vous est proposé en
premier lieu mesdames et messieurs les
députés de rectifier l'ONDAM pour 2023 à
hauteur de 2,8 milliards d'euros pour
intégrer les revalorisation salariales
qui ont été acquises notamment dans la
fonction publique et la dynamique des
soins de ville pour l'ONDAM 2024 avec
une évolution prévue à
plus à + 3,2 % hors dépenses liées à la
crise sanitaire cet onable sera bien sûr
supérieur à l'inflation préis
prévisionnelle au total c'est donc une
progression des moyens de 8 milliards
d'euros qui vous est présenté dans ce
PLFSS soit plus que le budget global du
ministère de la Justice il y a encore 2
ans nous n'en sommes pas du tout à la
cure d'austérité pour 2024
elle traduit par rapport au tendantiel
dynamique des dépenses effectivement des
mesures de maîtrise d'économie ou plus
exactement des mesures de ralentissement
de la dépense et d'efficience pour un
montant de 3,5 milliards d'euros que le
contexte rend indispensable ces mesures
de maîtrise sont de plusieurs natures et
visent à responsabiliser chacun sans
stigmatiser personne les professionnels
de santé comme les assurés bénéficiaires
ou les employeurs sont tous concernés
pour atteindre notre cible des efforts
de modération des volumes et de baisse
des prix doivent permettre de freiner la
Haus des dépenses de produits de santé
des efforts d'efficience et de
pertinence sont prévus tant pour les
soins de ville et cela sera au cœur de
la négociation conventionnelle que
l'ensemble des syndicats de médecins ont
accepté de reprendre avec ces termes
précisément dans la lettre de cadrage
que j'ai adressé au directeur général de
l'assurance maladie elle sera donc au
cœur de la négociation conventionnel
mais ce sera aussi le cas pour l'hôpital
avec par exemple une plus grande
efficience dans les achats simultanément
aux efforts très importants que nous
financions en matière d'attractivité et
notamment de réhaussement des
rémunérations enfin des efforts de
responsabilisation des assurés sont
également envisagés avec plusieurs
réflexions ouvertes dont vous avez eu
connaiss et dont nous aurons l'occasion
de débattre ce texte nous pouvons en
être fier nous pouvons en être fier car
il continue d'investir massivement dans
la protection sociale et dans la santé
des Français nous pouvons en être fier
car il développe de nouveaux axes en
matière de prévention en santé et
d'accès de nos concitoyens aux thérapies
dont ils ont besoin nous pouvons en être
fi aussi car il traduit nos engagements
dans le champ de l'autonomie par exemple
en donnant les moyens de recruter dans
les épades ou de mieux identifier
accompagner les enfants en situation
handicap nous pouvons en être fiers car
il porte ses priorités tout en assurant
la maîtrise et dépenses condition
indispensable pour préserver notre
système à court et à long terme nous
pouvons en être fier enfin car ce texte
apporte des mesures nouvelles et très
fermes dans la lutte contre la fraude
qui est un enjeu financier mais aussi et
surtout un enjeu de cohésion sociale
aussi ce PLFSS répond je le crois à
l'aspiration des Français en faveur d'un
système de protection sociale équitable
et pérennisé ce PLFSS s'inscrit donc
pleinement dans notre trajectoire de
maîtrise des dépenses publiques et dans
l'objectif de soutenabilité de long
terme mais ce PLFSS n'est pour autant
pas synonyme d'austérité loin de là
c'est un texte qui traduit encore une
fois une priorité très claire donnée à
nos politique sociale et à notre
politique de santé ce texte assure des
moyens historiquement élevés aux
établissements de santé ces derniers ces
derniers ont bénéficié d'un important
soutien financier de l'Assurance Maladie
ces dernières années par exemple 6,5
milliards d'euros ont été versés depuis
2020 au titre du désendettement
hospitalier le segégur a représenté au
total 13,4 milliards d'euros en 2023
pour investir et pour des mesures
salarial je rappelle aussi qu'un
amortisseur électricité a été mis en
place pour faire face à la des prix de
l'énergie et a permis de limiter la
hausse des coûts pour un montant estimé
à près de 300 millions d'euros le
soutien public au financement des
hôpitaux restera massif en
2024 le sous-objectif qui leur est dédié
dépassera en effet 100 milliards d'euros
pour la 2è année consécutive soit un
niveau
historique s'agissant plus
spécifiquement de la compensation de
l'inflation en 2023 qui fait l'objet de
plusieurs amendements de votre part je
rappelle qu'elle est prise en compte
dans l'endame 2023 pour une enveloppe de
800 millions d'euros pour les hôpitaux
et plus de 200 millions d'euros destinés
aux établissements médicaux-sociaux dans
le champ médicau-social long dame 2023
intègre les 100 millions d'euros
annoncés par la première ministre cet
été dans le cadre d'un nouveau fond
d'urgence ce dispositif permettra
d'accompagner les epads et les services
à domicile rencontrant des difficultés
financières ce PLFSS prévoit aussi dans
la continuité notamment du rapport de
Madame Christine piresbonne une
évolution du financement des épad pour
les départements volontaires plus
largement l'ONDA médico-social couvrant
le champ du grand âge et du handicap
dépassera pour la première fois les 30
milliards d'euros enfin de manière
transversale aux établissements
sanitaires et médicos-sociaux le PLFSS
prolonge les acquis des dernières années
en matière de revalorisation salariale
en 2024 les mesures de revalorisation et
d'attractivité décidé en 2023 coûteront
3,3 milliards d'euros si on inclut le
relèvement du point d'indice de 3,5 % de
2022 ce sont 6,2 milliards d'euros de
gain pour les professionnels l'année
prochaine qui viennent s'ajouter aux
mesures séures prises au moment de la
crise sanitaire au total longondame 2024
progressera donc de 3,2 % un niveau
supérieur à celui de l'inflation qui
s'établira quant à elle à 2,5 %. sur le
quinena l'ONDAM sera systématiquement
supérieur à l'inflation si nous agissons
donc sur les ressources de la sécurité
sociale de nouvelles mesures de maîtrise
et dépenses sont nécessaires dès 2024 et
d'autres devont être prises à partir de
2025 en 2024 longam intgre ainsi 3,5
milliards d'euros d'économie ces
économies seront un effort réparti en
entre tous les acteurs du système de
santé c'est-à-dire aussi bien les
assurés que les prescripteurs ou les
industriels je veux par ailleurs
souligner que les mesures d'économie que
nous proposons répondent non seulement à
des enjeux financiers mais aussi à des
impératifs sanitaires et
environnementaux ce
PLFSS confirme ainsi qu'il existe une
voie pour une forme de sobriété et que
les objectifs financiers sanitaires et
environnementaux peuvent être
réconciliés ces trois 5 milliard d'euros
d'économie seront donc un effort partagé
1,3 milliard d'euros d'économie sont
attendus de la responsabilisation des
assurés cette dernière peut passer par
un ensemble de leviers qui ne relève pas
nécessairement de mesures législatives
en PLFSS et qui sont en train d'être
travaillé et concerté par le ministre en
charge de la santé et de la prévention
les économies pourraient ainsi résulter
de la hausse des franchises et par
participation forfaitaire qui n'ont pas
augmenté depuis leur création il y a
près de 20 ans ou de la hausse du ticket
modérateur correspondant à la part de
prise en charge par l'assurée ou par sa
mutuelle une telle évolution est par
exemple intégrée au PLFSS s'agissant des
soins dentaires la responsabilisation
des assurés doit aussi permettre des
dépenses plus efficientes par exemple en
recourant au transport sanitair partagés
qui est également plus favorable à
l'environnement ou en privilég
chaque fois que possible les médicaments
génériques ou biosimilaires la
consommation des médicaments doit être
maîtrisée il en va de la responsabilité
des assurés comme des
prescripteurs 1,3 milliard d'euros
d'économie sont attendus également sur
les dépenses de mé médicaments et
dispositifs médicaux dont 1 milliard au
titre de la baisse des prix et 300
millions d'euros du fait de la baisse et
volume pour y parvenir deux mesures sont
prévues dans le PLF F SS la première
conditionne la délivrance
d'antibiotiques pour certaines
pathologies à la réalisation d'un test
en confirmant l'utilité la deuxième
prévoit d'activer des mesures d'épargne
telles que le conditionnement à l'unité
et les ordonnances conditionnelles en
cas de risque de rupture de stock de
médicaments je souhaite d'ailleurs que
des travaux soient engagés pour
généraliser ces mesures en dehors des
périodes de rupture d'approvisionnement
900 millions d'euros d'économie enfin
viendront des soins de ville des mesures
d'efficience à l'hôpital j'ai souhaité
ce que ce PLF SS comme d'ailleurs le PLF
soit celui de la lutte contre la fraude
c'est un impératif d'équité et de
justice sociale pour l'ensemble des
assurés je voudrais aussi revenir sur la
mesure concernant le contrôle des arrêts
de travail je sais qu'elle suscite des
inquiétudes mais nous avons trouvé un
bon équilibre la mesure simplifie le
circuit de contrôle des arrêts maladies
et rend ce contrôle plus effectif tout
en préservant les droits des assurés la
politique familiale ne saurait devenir
une politique de redistribution ou de
correction des inégalités elle est
d'abord une politique qui appuie et qui
soutient toutes les familles dans le
respect de leur choix il s'agit aussi de
nos aînés de nos parents et du soutien à
leur autonomie nous faisons ainsi
grandir la branche autonomie pour
relever le défi démographique qui est
devant nous soutenir toutes les familles
c'est évidemment soutenir tous les âges
de la vie il s'agit encore des personnes
en situation de cap pour leur assurer
tout simplement une vie comme les autres
parmi les autres pour que le droit
commun s'applique à tous Nous créons
d'ici 2030 50000 solutions pour garantir
l'inclusion et la participation des
personnes en situation de handicap à
toutes les étapes de leur vie les
familles d'abord elles sont dans toute
leur diversité le premier maillon de
notre société le creuser des
apprentissages fondamentaux de la vie
collective et de l'expression des
solidarités le retour du du terme
famille dans la dénomination du
ministère n'est d'ailleurs pas un hasard
c'est la réaffirmation d'une priorité de
nos politiques publiques je souhaite
m'inscrire dans la ligée de ce choix
fort que notre pays a fait après la
guerre aider toutes les familles et s'en
donner les moyens la branche famille
cher Paul Christophe consacre comme vous
le savez plus de 50 milliards d'euros
chaque année à cet objectif avec une
hausse du budget de 2 milliards d'euros
en 2024 et une trajectoire qui atteindra
63 milliards d'euros de dépenses en 2027
notamment avec la mise en place du
complément de mode de garde pour toutes
les familles
monoparentales pour mettre en œuvre
concrètement cette politique familiale
le PLFSS intègre à la fois des aides
monétaires comme l'aide de soutien aux
familles c'est-à-dire la pension
alimentaire minimale que nous avons
revalorisé augmenté de 50 % l'année
dernière mais aussi de nouveaux moyens
pour renforcer les services aux familles
simplifier leur vie et mieux répondre à
leurs besoins en respectant leurs choix
en 2024 les moyens consacré à la
politique familiale augmenteront
notamment pour mettre en œuvre le
chantier du service public de la petite
enfance qui vise à garantir à tout
parents l'accès à une solution d'accueil
et de qualité en toute sécurité pour
leurs enfants en crèche chez une
assistante maternelle proche de CZ de
chez eux et financièrement accessible et
je remercie le compromis qui a été
trouvé en commission mixte paritaire par
les parlementaires et notamment la
rapporteur Christine lenabour en tout ce
sont 6 milliards d'euros qui seront
consacrés à ce service publ jusqu'en
2027 pour revaloriser les professionnels
de la petite enfance soutenir
l'investissement et le fonctionnement
des crèches et engager la dynamique
d'ouverture des 200000 solutions
d'accueil manquantes aujourd'hui que ce
soit en accueil collectif ou en accueil
individuel en 2030 un français sur 3IS
aura plus de 60 ans et pour la première
fois de l'histoire de notre pays les
plus de 65 ans seront plus nombreux que
les moins de 15 ans en cohérence donc
avec cette nécessité d' adaptation
l'objectif global de dépenses qui
finance vous le savez nos établissements
pour personnes âgées et personnes en
situation de handicap augmentera de 4 %
en 2024 soit bien plus que les 2,6 %
d'inflation anticipée cette hausse
importante des moyens traduit le respect
de nos engagements envers les familles
et les professionnels du secteur ces
engagements vous les connaissez je l'ai
dit je crois profondément au libre choix
des individus et le premier choix des
Français c'est d'abord de pouvoir
vieillir chez eux c'est pour répondre à
cette volonté que nous avons entrepris
le virage domiciliaire et que nous
mettrons en œuvre dès 2024 ma prime
adapte une nouvelle aide financière pour
adapter le logement et surtout pour
prévenir aussi la perte d'autonomie avec
les moyens du PLFSS 2024 nous allons
également poursuivre le développement de
nouveaux centres de ressources
territoriaux pour enfin décloisonner les
interventions auprès des personnes âgées
à domicile et simplifier leurs
démarchees ces centres de ressources
s'inscrivent évidemment dans la
dynamique du service public
départemental de l'autonomie qui devra
permettre d'avoir enfin un guichet
unique humain physique pour mettre fin
au parcours du combattant voir parfois
d'hérance des personnes directement
concernées mais aussi de leur famillees
le PLFSS 2024 concrétise une nouvelle
étape dans notre engagement de 50000
postes supplémentaires dans les éepades
c'était 3000 postes en 2023 ce sera 6000
postes en 2024 de soignants
supplémentaires regruter ce n'est pas
qu'une question de hausse des moyens
même si c'est bien de les garantir c'est
aussi une question d'attractivité et
c'est pour ça que ça ne se fait pas en
un jour c'est pour cela que j'ai obtenu
que les infirmiers et les aides
soignants en NPAD public bénéficie de la
même mesure de revalorisation pour le
travail de nuit et les jours fériers que
leurs collègues dans les établissements
publics sanitaires c'est pour cela que
j'ai pu annoncer aussi aujourd'hui son
extension au secteur privé non lucratif
parce qu'il faut encore une fois que
sanitaire et médico sociciale avance de
paire la semaine dernière en commission
nous avons examiné plus de 1400 am
amendement c'est un record à l'issue de
plus de 35 heur de débat soit le double
comparé au débat de en commission à la
fin de la dernière législature ce texte
n'a finalement pas été adopté je
regrette que nos oppositions FFI des
nombreux amendements que nous avons
adoptés dans l'intérêt des Français de
quoi parlons-nous d'un budget de la
Sécurité sociale de 643 milliards
d'euros pour protéger nos concitoyens
soit un/3 de notre richesse nationale
c'est-à-dire quat points de plus en
moyenne que les pays européens
ce PLFSS que nous avons à examiner est
un texte de responsabilité collective
une responsabilité dans l'équilibre
financier de la sécurité sociale il acte
en effet la poursuite du redressement
des comptes de la Sécurité sociale le
déficit des régimes obligatoires de base
et du fond de solidarité vieillesse a
été diminué de moitié par rapport à 2022
soit 8,8 milliards en 2023 sur
l'ensemble de ce périmètre les dépenses
qui atteindront 610 milliards,9 d'euros
en 2023 ont augmenté de 100 milliards
entre 2019 et 2023 ce qui traduit le
dynamisme des dépenses de sécurité
sociale en particulier en matière de
retraite et de santé dans un contexte
marqué par le vieillissement de la
population la gestion de crisees
sanitaire des revalorisations salariales
historiques et une augmentation
considérable du niveau des prestations
sociales indexées sur
l'inflation comme pour chaque texte
budgétaire depuis le début de la
législature l'ombre du 493 plane sur
l'examen en séance d'autant plus que ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale a été et
c'est inédit rejeté en commission les
insoumis défendent une motion de rejet
préalable dans l'espoir que l'Assemblée
nationale rejette définitivement le
budget de la Sécurité
sociale ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale a été rejeté en
commission c'est donc en toute cohérence
que j'arrive devant vous pour défendre
cette motion de rejet au nom de mon
groupe la France insoumise si ce texte a
été rejeté en commission c'est parce
qu'il ne donne aucun moyen pour sauver
notre système de santé au bord du
gouffre prenons l'exemple de l'article 2
l'ondame 2023 n'est pas du tout
suffisant on l'a dit l'année dernière
mais personne ne nous a écouté et
résultat il faut rajouter de l'argent
mais la ralonge est toujours très
insuffisante tout le monde vous le dit
il DME pour londame 2024 c'est pour
pourqui il faut voter cette motion ce
n'est qu'une suite logique d'autant plus
pour toutes les personnes ici présentes
qui ont applaudi les soignants durant le
confinement car ce texte ne le rend
absolument pas hommage donc non il ne
s'agit pas d'un comportement
irresponsable non nous ne sommes pas des
inconscients il s'agit un de respecter
la volonté qui s'est exprimée en
commission avant l'arrivée du 493 et 2
de mettre fin à la CE de notre système
de santé il y a de très bonnes raisons
de rejeter ce texte d'autant plus dans
le contexte très inquiétant dans lequel
nous l'examinons l'hôpital est en crise
inédite dont la situation des urgences
montre l'intensité combien de patients
ont trouvé porte close devant l'hôpital
les appels auquun sont totalement
engorgés alors que faire quand les
urgences sont fermées qu'il n'y a
personne au bout du fil cette situation
vous paraît caricaturale c'est pourtant
ce que vivent bon nombre de nos
concitoyens tous les services sont en
pénurie de soignant récemment ce sont
même les services de néonatologie qui
ont fait l'actualité pas de lit pas de
personnel pour prendre en charge les
nouveau nés ce qui met gravement leur
vie en danger les chiffres c'est la
mortalité infantile publiée récemment
nous ont d'ailleurs tous choqués car en
France en 2023 ils augmentent je vous
parle aujourd'hui au nom de toutes ces
familles qui vivent un cauchemar
poursuivons en parlant des épades les
multiples alertes n'ont rien donné la
maltraitance institutionnelle est
toujours le quotidien des résidents et
des soignants le privé lucratif lui
continue de distribuer des dividendes
pendant que les résidents n'ont même pas
le droit à une toilette réglementaire et
sont rationnés décidément leur gris fait
recette y compris avec l'argent public
l'état de la santé mentale de nos
concitoyens est alarmant nous croisons
tous dans nos permanences des personnes
déprimées anxieuses et désespéré de ce
que vous leur faites subir plus d'un
quart des Français consomment des
anxiollytiques des antidépresseurs des
somnifères et autres médicaments
psychotrop et que dire de la santé
mentale de nos enfants si dégradés en
établissement psychiatrique c'est aussi
la fermeture de lit le manque de
personnel et parfois la contention faute
d'autres moyens vous avez des troubles
vous faites une crise il n'y a personne
pour s'occuper de vous ce sera donc la
contrainte physique ou médicamenteuse
bienvenue en France en
2023 regardons aussi ce qu'il en est de
la santé au travail les accidents du
travail sont légion et l'exposition au
risque psychosociaux est de plus en plus
élevé nous avons vu encore cette été des
personnes obligées de travailler sous
des chaleurs caniculaires les
conséquences sur la santé sont
dramatiques peu importe pour vous chacun
doit être au travail à tout prix et
maintenant en nous forçant à travailler
2 ans de plus après votre réforme des
retraite que ce PLFSS continue à mettre
en œuvre pendant ce temps la France est
aussi devenu un désert médical géant
dans lequel les patients ne trouve même
plus de médicaments pénurie d'amoxicyine
pénurie de traitement pour les maladies
chroniques pénurie de vaccin contre la
broncholite pardon et j'en passe nous
sommes sollicités quotidiennement par
des personnes paniquées de ne pas
trouver leur tra
on atteint des sommets quand votre
solution à la pénurie est de demander
qu'il ne soit plus prescrit le ridicule
serait presque risible si ce n'était pas
aussi grave et quand je prends l'exemple
de la cortisone dont tant de gens ont
besoin aucune réponse également le non
recours au soins atint des chiffres
jamais vus faute de moyens ou de service
de proximité les gens renoncent à
consulter à se faire des pisté et bien
sûr dans un cercle vicieux infernal tout
cela grave d'autant plus leur état de
santé dans votre monde de la naissance à
la mort personne n'est épargné il n'y a
qu'un seul mot pour qualifier votre
bilan la catastrophe et ce pfss ne fera
qu'aggraver la situation c'est pourquoi
je défends avec vigueur cette Monçon de
Reet et je vais donc mettre au voix par
scrutin public cette motion de rejet
préalable le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 404 exprimés
395 majorité 198 pour 180 contre 215
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
[Applaudissements]
adopté la motion de rejet de la France
insoumise n'est pas adoptée la
discussion générale se poursuit avec les
prises de parole des orateurs de chaque
groupe
il fallait un mot pour qualifier le
budget santé
2024 je retiendrai le mot
prévention un mot qui traduit la
capacité de nos politiques à maintenir
nos concitoyens en bonne santé quand on
soignera jamais mieux un patient qu'en
lui donnant les moyens de s'informer de
suivre sa santé ainsi que les outils
permettant d'améliorer son hygiène de
vie tous autant que nous sommes nous
pouvons et nous devons être attentifs au
risqu en santé selon les âges selon les
métiers selon les rythmes individuels
selon les handicaps il est possible d'ID
d'identifier les menaces qui pèsent sur
notre santé allons-y nous constatons une
pénurie humaine dans la totalité des
filières de soignants et des dents un
manque de moyens financiers criant pour
la médecine de ville pour les hôpitaux
publics et privés pour le Médico-Social
pour nos épades les deux symboles en
sont les deux deux extrêmes de la vie en
néonatologie ce sont 1200 nouveau nés
fragiles qui selon une étude récente
n'ont pu être sauvé faute de moyens nous
faisant passer de la 3e à la 20e place
de la mortalité infantile et à l'autre
bout c'est l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé qui recule pourtant les
prélèvements sont là sur les 602
milliards pour 2023 qui aurait dû
suffire si on était revenu à l'esprit
même de notre sécurité sociale et cyber
ne laissez pas filer la dette tolérant
une gestion catastrophique et bien pire
imposant en même temps l'austérité dès
lors empêtré comme vous l'êtes dans un
piège que vous vous êtes vous-même tendu
vous n'avez plus d'autre choix qu'un
bidouillage de transfert de comptes un
financement toujours plus fiscalisé ou
un retour massif à la dette alors qu'il
faudrait de l'ambition et du dynamisme
et les quelques propositions auxquelles
nous avons adhéré le dépistage du Syto
mgalovirus l'octroi de la complémentaire
solidarité au plus fragile les gardes
dentaires ne sont que des broutilles
face aux besoins réels des Français sur
la forme la discussion en commission a
été marqué par l'incroyable
psychorigidité des rapporteurs 94
amendements seulement adoptés sur les
plus de 1200 discutés pourquoi présenter
des amendements dans ces conditions et
que dire si même le sujet était très
important de la prévention des maladies
sexuellement transmissible qui ont pris
plus de 5 % de notre temps pas une
seconde sur les déserts médicaux ni sur
les déserts pharmaceutiques sur l'état
de faillite de beaucoup de nues urgences
pas non plus de débat sur le tiers de
nos hôpitaux en quasi dépôt de bilan et
sur les épades qui ne savent même pas
comment Fayer leur facture d'électricité
cet hiver en 2020 Emmanuel Macron
annoncé un plan massif d'investissement
en 2023 on ne parle plus
d'investissement massif mais vous
mesdames messieurs les ministres
monsieur le ministre de la Santé vous
parlez d'une trajectoire responsable une
trajectoire responsable qui s'inscrit
dans la longue lignée des trajectoires
responsables que les soignants patients
travailleur travaille ailleurs ont dû
subir la vérité c'est que sur le fond
comme sur la forme la trajectoire que
vous nous proposez n'a rien de
responsable vous continuez d'étouffer à
coup de budget àamaigri un système de
santé qui ne tient déjà plus mesdames
messieurs les ministres vous opposez une
trajectoire responsable à des supposés
irresponsables mais les irresponsable
c'est
vous déjà déjà que faisons-nous
ici toute la semaine dernière nous avons
étudié votre proposition de budget
responsable pour la sécurité sociale et
pour la première fois de toute
l'histoire des lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale ce budget a été rejeté
ce budget est
tellement ce budget est tellement
responsable que vos propres députés ont
pris leur responsabilité et ne sont même
pas venus le voter en toute logique si
vous étiez un démocrate responsable vous
devriez prendre acte le budget proposé
n'est pas à la hauteur vous avez perdu
le vote et vous devriez revoir votre
copie au lieu de ça vous revenez avec le
même texte que celui que nous avons
rejeté et la première ministre va venir
prendre ses responsabilités pour sauver
pour vous sauver et passer ce budget par
la force par 493 faute d'avoir su
convaincre l'opposition mais même vos
propres députés nous l'avons dit le
compte n'y est pas et la situation est
relativement historique puisque en
commission des Affaires social le PLFSS
2024 n'a pas été
adopté c'est une c'est un signal fort
que nous avons souhaité envoyer au
gouvernement sur un PLFSS qui a été euh
construit sans aucune concertation et
sans écoute de son opposition les
hypothèses sur lequel vous avez bâti
longam sont malheureusement insincères
vous basez vos chiffres sur une
croissance 1,4 % alors que la BCE
prévoit 75 % de différence à 0,9 % et
une inflation à 2,5 alors que la BCE
prévoit une inflation à 3,2 %. le compte
n'y est pas non plus sur la famille qui
en 2023 était la variable d'ajustement
avec une ponction de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros nous faisons un bénéfice du
doute pour la ministre ministre berger
pour rétablir l'universalité des
allocations familiales j'espère qu'elle
pourra le confirmer puisque nous le
savons cette mesure supprimée par
François Hollande en 2012 a montré ses
effets avec un taux de natalité le plus
bas depuis 1945 avec ne serait-ce que
sur le 1emier semestre 2023 - 25000
naissances concernant l'amendement
Creton nous nous félicitons
effectivement de voir la création de
10000 places pour sortir ces personnes
des places dans les centres d' handicapé
pour réserver pour nos enfants enfin
concernant l'autonomie le compte n'y est
pas non plus puisque malgré les 015
points de CSG qui viendront en janvier
le 2,6 milliards ne suffira pas à
financer la totalité de cette 5e branche
en effet le reste à charge moyen pour
une personne âgée en épad d' 1000 €
moyen par par foyer ce qui est
extrêmement important et nous nous avons
fait un certain nombre de propositions
sur des moyens de financement que ça
soit le système assurantielle que ça
soit par capitalisation en lien avec la
Mutualité Française pour l'instant nous
sommes restés sans écoute de savoir quel
financement nous souhaitons pour quel
niveau d'autonomie en en sachant que le
le le virage domiciliaire est important
qu'il est le choix de vie d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens mais pour cela
il faut 380000 personnes en formation
pour les acteurs du domicile et que la
loi bien vieillir pour l'instant ne
pourvoit rien dans ses besoins de
formation des 380000 personnes enfin sur
le PLFSS nous n'avons rien vu non plus
sur les soins palliatifs je rappelle
qu'il y a encore 21 départements qui
sont dépourvus d'unité de soins
palliatifs donc monsieur le ministre je
vous le dis c'est le moment où jamais de
pouvoir suivre le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui estime le besoin à 1,6
milliards pour pouvoir mettre des soins
palliatifs pour tous accessibles partout
on compte sur vous monsieur le ministre
pour prendre en charge ces en jeux
plutôt qu'il ne soit régler dans le
solul projet de loi de la fin de vie de
la ministre lebudau enfin concernant la
branche maladie des efforts ont été
faits ça a été dit sur la vaccination
sur la gratuité des moyens de
contraception et sur les préservatifs
sur un dépistage du CMV au début de de
la grossesse mais le compte n'y est pas
sur un certain nombre de secteurs nous
l'avons déjà dit sur l'hôpital sur les
cliniques privées sur les épales 49 % de
nos hôpitaux publics sont en déficit 40
% de nos cliniques privées sont en
déficit 60 % de nos épades sont en
déficit et le PLFSS 2024 avec les 2
milliards qui manque pour faire suivre
pour couvrir pardon les besoins de
l'inflation et les revalorisations de la
garde et de la permanence de nuit ne
suffiront pas alors on peut se
satisfaire effectivement de l'amendement
des républicains sur la pluranalité des
ressources qui ont été passer à 5 ans
c'est un premier pas mais on voit bien
que pour l'instant il manque l'essentiel
à savoir une loi programmation de la
santé pluriannuelle les libéraux non
plus ne s'y retrouvent pas puisque il
n'y aura aucun virage ambulatoire aucun
virage domicilière sans u 40 % de nos
infirmières envisagent en libéral
envisagent d'arrêter leur profession à 5
ans alors qu'on sait qu'elles sont
complètement écrasé par l'inflation
puisqu'elles ont une une non
revalorisation de leurs actes depuis
2009 avec malheureusement un tô un un un
plein d'essence qui ne cesse d'augmenter
et qui réduit leur marge en permanence
concernant enfin les revalorisations des
consultations le 1,50 € a bien a bien
coupé les liens avec la médecine
libérale et nous espérons que les
renégociation vont pouvoir revaloriser
correctement les prestations oui ce
projet de loi s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire de programmation des
finances public oui les comptes publics
se doivent de tendre vers l'équilibre
cette exigence de responsabilité a animé
le groupe démocrate dans l'examen du
texte en commission vouloir financer de
nouvelles dépenses par des recettes
équivalentes ce n'est pas aller à la
rencontre à l'encontre de la solidarité
c'est au contraire de la rendre possible
et surtout
pérenne nous nous devons de veiller au
bon financement de notre sécurité
sociale pour être capable de faire face
au lendemain et pour établir un PLFSS
sérieux et responsable il faut le
replacer dans le contexte du
moment le contexte c'est d'abord celui
d'un système de santé qui porte encore
les stigmates de la crise sanitaire le
premier d'entre eux étant la fatigue et
la lcitude que ressent encore trop de
personnel
soignant les conséquences de cette crise
qui a démontré à la fois les fragilités
et la résilience de notre système de
santé se traduisent également par des
déficits persistants 11,2 milliards
d'euros cette année dont nous ne pouvons
pas nous
satisfaire l'essentiel de
l'accompagnement d'urgence de la crise
sanitaire est derrière nous désormais
avec seulement 200 millions d'euros de
dépenses provisionnées pour 2024 en
revanche le projet de loi poursuit la
dynamique d'augmentation salariale
initiée par le segure de de la santé
avec une enveloppe de 3,3 milliards
d'euros dédié à l'amélioration de la
rémunération des personnels médicaux et
paramédicaux les conséquences tirées de
la crise covid se retrouvent aussi dans
l'investissement renforcé en santé et
dans la lutte contre les pénurie de
médicament le contexte de ce PLFSS c'est
aussi celui d'une forte inflation d'un
côté et d'une responsabilité budgétaire
de l'autre et dans ce cadre contraint
les pensions de retraite et les
prestations social se verront
revaloriser d'environ 5 % et l'ONDAM va
progresser de 3,2 % alors que
l'inflation est prévue à 2,6 en
2024 est-ce que nous mesurons la portée
exceptionnelle de ces efforts est-ce que
nous réalisons que l'ondame a progresser
de près de 64 milliards depuis 2017
est-ce que vous voulez cont voter contre
ces avancées d'abord je veux vous dire
en étant attaché à la grandeur du débat
parlementaire et je le dis avec une une
gravité désabusée et avec la tristesse
du désœuvrement que malheureusement
cette année encore une épée de
damoclesès surpombe nos débats
d'aujourd'hui et les rang stérile
inutile et vain c'est le 493 devenu une
sorte de fatalité inévitable avec lui
tout est joué à d'avance Dansel quelques
minutes ou plutôt dans quelques heures
la première ministre montera cette
estrade et psalemo dira à nouveau l'air
qui commence à être familier à
l'ensemble des Français j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la première et la deuxième partie du
projet de loi de financement pour
2024 et votre projet de loi pour la le
budget de la Sécurité Sociale a beau
avoir été rejeté en commission des
affaires sociales bah en fait vous n'en
tirerez aucune conséquence pire vous
prétendez chercher des sujets de
consensus sans jamais faire de
concession ce qui admettez est un
exercice un petit peu étonnant
manifestant votre refus d'une démocratie
parlementaire vivante et consistante je
ne reviens pas sur les épisodes qui ont
émaillé toute l'année
2022-2023 on nous disait vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir le Conseil
national de la refondation avec ses
volets sur la santé avec ses volets sur
le Bien Vieillir sur quoi tout cela
a-t-il débouché de concret dans
cplfss je ne reviens pas non plus sur
l'initiative politique d'ampleur que le
Président de la République avait
souhaité convoquer à la rentrée cela
n'aura eu aucun effet dans la séquen
budgétaire que nous traversons bref à
coup d'opération de communication vous
plongez la France dans une initiative
politique d'ampleur improvisé en continu
vous n'arrêtez pas de répéter aussi que
vous voulez trouver des compromis de
projet ou des majorités de projet mais
dans les faits vous faites exactement le
contraire l'an dernier
alors vous vous étiez avec la minorité
présidentielle au moins astreint à
organiser des groupes transpartisans au
niveau de la commission des affaires
sociales les débout boucher avait été
limité mais ce format avait le mérite
d'exister cette année c'est fini vous ne
faites même plus semblant pas plus que
je me rappelle la promesse de votre
prédécesseur de dire nous travaillerons
très en amont au PLFSS je vous ai
entendu prochain je vous ai entendu nous
le dire à nouveau cher Aurélien Rousseau
bien écoutez nous vérifierons si nous
sommes capables de travailler non pas 15
jours ou 3 semaines auparavant comme
avec vos compte de Ségure ou d'une
certaine manière vous nous présentiez
les arbitrages déjà réalisés ce n pas
comme cela que vous allez créer des
majorités de projet et même quand nous
tentons de jouer le jeu de la
coconstruction bien vous rejetez en bloc
ça me permet à cet instant et je le dis
devant le ministre casazenav de revenir
sur une petite entourloupe quand vous
nous indiquez que c'est sur la base du
rapport de Marc Ferraci et de Jérôme
gage que vous allez prendre des
amendements de gel des seuils de calcul
des 25 et 35 ce n'était pas la
conclusion à laquelle nous étions
arrivés la conclusion à laquelle nous
étions arrivés c'est que les
exonérations de cotisation sociale
peuvent être questionner elles doivent
l'être que de manière certaine entre 2,5
et 3,5 SMIC elles n'ont aucune impact
aucun impact sur l'emploi et sur la
compétitivité et nous proposions
purement et simplement de les supprimer
c'était tellement partagé que j'avais
déposé un amendement avec quelqu'un de
chez vous avec sachoulier président de
la commission des lois et membre de la
majorité bah malgré cela il est pas
retenu le consensus coproduit par des
parlementaires ne retient pas votre
attention je pourrais vous citer aussi
le travail fait sur les déserts médicaux
dans le cadre du groupe de travail
transpartisan porté par mon collègue
Guillaume Garot je pourrais vous parler
aussi de la volonté affichée sur tous
les bancs de l'hémicycle de travailler
ensemble à une loi de programmation sur
le grand âge à musclé j'y reviendrai le
travail sur ce sujet au contraire chaque
initiative est Brié bridée muselée
cadenacé et au final nous nous
retrouvons avec des amendements que nous
avons pu réussir à faire voter en
commission mais dont nous savons qu'ils
vont pas passer à la roulette du 493 où
quelque part on ne saisù on ira piocher
tel ou tel amendement pour retenir je ne
sais pas par exemple si ceux que j'ai
avec d'autres pu contribuer à faire
voter pour sanctionner de manière plus
efficace les professionnels de santé
fraudeur en procédant systématiquement
et totalement au remboursement des
exonérations de cotisation sociale je ne
sais pas au moment où je vous parle si
vous le retiendrez dans le fameux 493
euh et pourtant je le dis avec beaucoup
de franchises euh nous reconnaissons que
ce projet comporte des avancées comme à
chaque fois que nous saluons encore
heureux seraiis-je tenté de dire le
souci c'est que systématiquement elle
s'arrête au milieu du gay évidemment la
gratuité des préservatifs et des
protections menstruelles pour les moins
de 26 ans c'est très bien mais bigre
pourquoi s'arrêter à 26 ans je pense
aussi au lancement de la campagne
nationale de vaccination contre le
papillomarie virus dès la classe de 5e
de 5e un/3 des jeunes hommes de plus de
15 ans sont porteurs d'un papilloma
virus et environ et environ 20 % sont
atteints d'un type de HPV qui pourrait
engendrer un cancer il y a urgence et
vous avez pris à sa juste mesure le
dossier mais pourquoi une minorité et je
sais que ce cet angle mort vous
préoccupe monsieur le ministre une
minorité de collèges privés freine des
cas de fer pour le déploiement pourquoi
ne pas avoir déployé la réalisation de
campagne hors les murs de l'école dans
les clubs sportifs dans les MJC et
d'essayer d'élargir j'espère que vous
pourrez reprendre cette proposition nous
saluons aussi enfin le début de
commencement de l'amorce d'un début de
la fusion des sections soins et
dépendances le problème le problème
c'est que cette mesure réclamé par tous
les acteurs elle était dans le rapport
de Dominique Libau mais en choisissant
l'adhésion volontaire des conseils
départementaux il y a un risque d'une
réforme à minima et surtout d'un
financement des épades à deux vitesses
qui va complexifier la vie des
opérateurs et notamment de ceux qui
agissent à l'échelle national jamais
aucun gouvernement depuis tous ceux qui
se sont succédés depuis 2017 n'ont
jamais autant accompagné l'hôpital alors
peut-être on peut mettre ça sur le dos
effectivement de la crise sanitaire qui
a peut-être fait prendre conscience que
l'hôpital nécessitait un remède de
cheval mais quand on voit le montant
d'investissement quand on voit le séure
de la santé et donc l'effort qui a été
fait les 9 milliards d'euros versés pour
les salaires et je ne parle que de là de
de l'hôpital ce sont des efforts
qu'aucun gouvernement par le passé et on
peut remonter loin dans le temps aucun
gouvernement n'avait n'avait fait alors
évidemment ça n'est peut-être pas assez
mais je tiens à à le dire la deuxième
chose qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'effectivement pour sortir notre
système de santé des de la des des des
des tensions financières que l'on que
que l'on évoque et que l'on connaît et
bien il faudra engager des
transformations profondes nécessaires et
ce que souhaite d'ailleurs le président
de la République et ce qu'entame ce
PLFSS j'y reviendrai dans dans quelques
minutes parce que la crise est profonde
et la crise d'attractivité des métiers
du soin elle est aussi très preignante 3
ans et demi après le premier confinement
nous devons tenir un discours de vérité
nous devons un de discours de vérité
pour les Français nous devons tourner le
dos quoi qu'il en coûte euh quel que
soit la douleur et la difficulté que
cela représente disonsle clairement ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale n'a pas de majorité il
a été rejeté en commission et il serait
rejeté s'il était soumis au vote dans
cet
hémicycle les outils de la Constitution
vous permettront de l'imposer mais dans
ces cas-là vous porterez seul la
responsabilité d'un cadrage budgétaire
en desessà des besoins des Français et
des Françaises vous porterez seul la
responsabilité d'une politique qui
notre modèle social et notre santé
publique au capitaine mon
capitaine
[Applaudissements]
carpédiem cuœille le jour
présent j'ai conscience de la fugacité
de ce moment de sa rareté autant que de
son étrangeté nous ne savons pas encore
à quel instant le fil se brisera à quel
instant l'épée tombera à quel instant
son tranchant arrêtera nos débats à quel
instant vous vous imposerez votre choix
c'est toute la magie du suspense pour ce
qu'il en reste car les feuilles mortes
se ramassent à l'appel comme les 493
aussi d'ailleurs certains d'entre nous
ont dit que celui qui vient nous
l'aurions bien mérité ah si la
commission des affaires sociales avait
sagement adopté cet objectif national de
dépense d'Assurance Maladie inquiétant
et ce budget indigeent mais non fait
inédit elle a rejeter votre projet une
première depuis la création des lois de
financement en 1996 et cela devrait vous
obliger à réfléchir et à changé
d'orientation à bouger le cadre et ce
que j'ai entendu dénoncer encore il y a
quelques instants c'est tout simplement
en réalité que nous sommes en désaccord
que peut-on dire de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
d'abord que c'est le même que le
précédent Empire et le précédent n'était
déjà pas terrible non seulement il
nétait pas terrible mais il a été
carrément marqué au fer rouge par la loi
rectificative de casse du droit à la
retraite qui a été imposé par un 493 à
un pays qui n'en voulait pas ce projet
de loi de financement porte l'estigmate
des premières conséquences ingrates de
cette loi indigne et c'est la première
raison pour laquelle il provoque notre
colère avec au passage des dispositions
qui ne tiennent pas debout concernant le
régime spécial des électriciens et
gaziers ensuite il prévoit de continuer
les exonérations massives de cotisation
sociale en commission un amendement a
été adopté par la majorité qui annule
une exonération sur les bons salaires et
qui supprime pour le même montant le peu
qui restait sur les bas salaires vous
êtes en réalité accro aux exo et vous
encouragez les bas salaires alors même
que vous êtes si peu enclin à augmenter
le salaire net vous ne pouvez pas vous
empêcher de raboter le salaire brut de
délégitimer la cotisation qui est
pourtant le fondement de notre
protection sociale cette année encore
2,5 milliards d'exonération de
cotisation sur les heures
supplémentaires ne seront pas compensé
la S sécurité sociale ne doit pas être
la variable d'ajustement des politiques
économiques il faut arrêter de la
sous-financer et investir l'argent de la
compensation dans la fonction publique
et les services publics qui sont en
crise en conséquence votre budget
prévoit une nouvelle compression des
dépenses de santé ces objectifs 3,2 sont
en dessous de l'augmentation
tendantielle voilà des années et des
années que vous demandez des économies à
l'hôpital public qui n'en finit pas de
s'enfoncer dans la crise le projet de de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui dans un
contexte de forte inflation et porté par
une volonté d'économie plus que de
réelle transition économie alors que
l'ensemble des structures et services
qu'ils soi sanitaires médicauxsoaux
sociaux font face à des tensions
extrêmes pour recruter et rendre
attractif les carrières tout en étant
confronté aux conséquences de
l'inflation que ce soit dans nos
hôpitaux ou dans nos éepad dans la santé
en général chacun s'accorde sur la
nécessité de réinvestir ses secteurs
financièrement et humainement assurément
nous en attendions davantage nous
attendions une ambition il ne s'agit pas
ici de critiquer le fait de chercher à
équilibrer le budget des comptes sociaux
particulièrement après la crise
sanitaire qui les a fragilisé mais de
dire que ces économies se font là ou de
notre point de vue il n'en faudrait pas
nous ne sommes pas semble-t-il les seuls
à le penser ce budget n'a pas réussi à
franchir le cap de la Commission et les
raisons en ce qui concerne le groupe lot
sont nombreuses je pense par exemple à
l'augmentation du ticket modérateur pour
les soins dentaires est-est-ce
prioritaire alors que nos concitoyens
connaissent une baisse continue de leur
pouvoir
d'achat je crois que notre système de
protection sociale mérite mieux que de
simples économies il a besoin aussi de
nouvelles ressources pas seulement parce
qu'il est en difficulté depuis plusieurs
années mais surtout pour faire face aux
besoins à venir qui sont croissants sur
l'accès aux soins il suffit de regarder
la situation des établissements de santé
pour comprendre que l'ONDAM 2023 et 2024
ne permettront pas de couvrir
l'inflation et les revalorisations
salariales sur les territoires insulair
et ultramarins confrontés à des surcûts
structurels nous ne pouvons plus
repousser sans cesse la revéoration des
coefficients géographique enfin sur le
soutien à l'autonomie qui était pourtant
affiché comme une priorité par le
Président de la République la déception
est grande ce texte ne répond clairement
pas aux enjeux liés au vieillissement de
la population
le transfert d'une fraction de CSG à la
CNSA représentera seulement 2,6
milliards d'euros en 2024 quand tous les
rapports sur ce sujet fixent les besoins
à près de 9 milliards je veux également
insister sur les métiers permettez-moi
de vous dire que la trajectoire de 50000
postes d'ici 2027 en épad n'est pas
crédible ni réalisable au regard des
actions que vous avez engagé jusqu'ici
combien de postes ont effectivement été
financés sur les 3000 budgetés en épad
dans 2000 203 comment comptez-vous
respecter la trajectoire des 50000 que
vous avez annoncé d'ici 2027 alors que
seulement 6000 sont prévus en
2024 pourtant nous sommes convaincus que
l'ouverture concrète de ces postes sur
les 3 années à venir contribuerait à
redonner une image positive de ces
métiers à améliorer leur attractivité à
faire revenir celles et ceux si nombreux
qui l'ont quitté le plus souvent pour
des raisons de condition de travail
c'est pourquoi je réfute l'argument
selon lequel il est inutile de créer des
postes au vu des difficultés de
recrutement actuelles je crois que vous
prenez le problème à l'envers le manque
d'attractivité de ces métiers est la
conséquence directe des conditions de
travail dans nos établissements et au
ratio d'encadrement trop faible qui
abîme et fragilise les personnels des
femmes et des hommes qui aiment pourtant
profondément leur métier mais qui
craquent et abandonnent car ils perdent
espoir c'est bien l'ampleur du désarroi
des professionnels et des structures qui
les emploient qui conduit cond à une
dégradation de l'accueil des soins et de
l'accompagnement des personnes d'abord
j'ai une pensée pour les soignants euh
je sais pas pour ceux qui nous regardent
mais ceux qui sont sûrement en train de
de travailler de les remercier qu'il soi
en ville à l'hôpital et d'ailleurs
redire ici que les remerciements ce ne
sont pas que des mots que nous les avons
revalorisé dans le cadre du segégure
c'était 10 milliards dans le cadre de ce
PLFSS c'est plus de 2 milliards sur les
révalorisations annoncées pendant
l'année c'est aussi l'augmentation euh
du des points d'indice je rappelle ici
1,5 points plus les 5 points plus
l'augmentation sur les points sur les
bas salaires mais je pense à eux sur la
hauteur des débats qu'on a pu avoir ce
soir et je crois que nos débats euh qui
vont commencer prendrai un intérêt pour
eux si on acceptait euh de considérer
que la situation de nos établissement ne
dépend pas uniquement euh de la
situation financière de ces
établissements oui il faut de la
l'argent c'est ce que nous avons fait je
le redis ici un N d'AM à 254 milliards
pour 2024 en augmentation de 3,2 % c'est
aussi une pensée pour les soignants mais
acceptons de dire que la démographie
médicale qui est en
augmentation dans les années qui
viendront avec la fin du numérus closus
que nous avons arrêté et une des raisons
aussi et la caricature des débats que
j'ai pu parfois entendre lors de cette
discussion n'est pas la hauteur à mon
avis de nos soignants sur le fait que le
budget a été rejeté en en commission
PLFSS a été a été rejeté bon c'est un
peu la même histoire que sur le PLF
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de PLFSS
alternatif on l'a pas vu se dessiner je
crois dans les débats ni même dans les
DG les prises de parole au moment de de
laadg et vous pourriez reconnaître la
particularité des textes financiers
parce que il y a quand même plus d'une
cinquantaine de textes qui ont été ici
même adoptés sans recours au 493 sans
recours au 493 il y a une spécificité
des textes financiers il y a une
spécificité des textes financiers ah ben
merci j'espère qu'on notera les
applaudissements du ce côté là de de
l'émicycle ces desésaccords ne
justifient pas de
s'arroger le le monopole comme dirait
l'autre de la dignité des soignants ou
des patients nous sommes ici tous dans
nos vies dans nos parcours moi je
considère que je n'ai pas à recevoir le
gouvernement n'a pas à recevoir quand il
a fait depuis
2019 les plus grandes augmentations de
rémunération des personnels soignants
contre lesquels vous avez
systématiquement voter dans les PLFSS le
gouvernement n'a pas de leçon de dignité
à recevoir et à titre plus le
gouvernement en général et les ministres
en particulier je dois vous dire que
beaucoup de pays nous envirer une
situation dans lequel 82 % 82 % des
soins sont pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie obligatoire 14 % 14
% complémentaires sont pris en charge
par la les assurances maladies
complémentaire donc je ne vois pas
monsieur le député d'aréville où est où
est le
rabougrissement de la protection où est
le
rabougrissement du bilan où est le Rabou
ement du
bilan mais il faut aller plus loin et ça
sans doute plus loin dans dans certains
faits et à forcierie plutôt que d'en
inventer qui a rejeté le budget en
commission des affaires sociales est-ce
que c'est la contre
maajorité est-ce que c'est la contre
maajorité qui tout à l'heure s'est
retrouvé dans un unanimisme grandiose
des deux côtés de cet hémicycle pour
voter une motion de rejet est-ce que
c'est ça la contre maajorité que vous
défendez votre raisonnement s'arrête là
où commence la cohérence de vos
positions sans majorité absolue
impossible de faire adopter le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est donc sans suspense que le
texte est adopté grâce à l'utilisation à
5 reprises de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution par la première ministre
ellisabeth
borne
ce PLFSS c'est un budget de 640
milliards d'euros pour notre modèle
social ce sont des moyens en hausse pour
notre santé pour l'autonomie des
personnes âgées et des personnes en
situation de handicap ce sont des
solutions d'accueil pour les jeunes
enfants ou encore des rémunérations
revalorisées pour nos soignants ce texte
renforce notre sécurité sociale nous en
avons besoin aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet
doit de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 je vous
remercie le budget de la Sécurité
sociale est définitivement adopté après
le rejet de la motion de censure déposée
dans la foulée de ce dernier 493 en
lecture définitive à
bientôt
[Musique]